c'est gilet jaune existe une population
qui existe qui a été mis sous le
boisseau pendant l'année et demi et deux
ans de virus mail en question n'ont pas
été réglés il faudrait simplement pas
qu'il le répète comme disait marx et
l'histoire se répète toujours de manière
comique la seconde fois qui devient la
caricature d'eux mêmes et qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à formuler encore une
fois leurs revendications
moi je crois qu'effectivement c'était un
mouvement qui a surpris tout le monde
notamment la classe politique à l'époque
où il arrive et pourtant on comprend
c'est ce ras-le-bol de cette france
invisible qui travaillent qui fait ou
qu'on lui demande et qui ne gagnent pas
qui perd systématiquement qui perd dans
la mondialisation qui perd en pouvoir
d'achat qui perd aussi en horizon de
futures et la réponse a été la violence
a rappelé vous ça a été une répression
violente des manifestations puis laisse
bouffe le grand débat où emmanuel macron
se met en scène et vole la parole
publique les cahiers de doléances eux
ont été enterrés au sous sol de la
bibliothèque nationale de france
sont-ils dollars on se rend compte que
les problèmes soulevés par les gilets
jaunes sont aggravées à la fois par la
crise sanitaire mais par la politique
des moulins de macron donc on a
davantage de précarité davantage de peur
de l'avenir davantage de problèmes de
pouvoir d'achat l'essence est plus cher
encore qu'à l'époque où les gilet jaune
commence et on a le même gouvernement et
on a les mêmes réponses et on ça ne peut
pas continuer comme ça et le problème
effectivement des gilets jaunes c'est de
dire que là ils refusent toujours
l'incarnation politique à dire que les
politiques finalement sont dangereux ou
ne peut pas leur faire confiance parce
que c'est un système qui nous ment donc
on est du côté de l'abstentionnisme plus
tôt et puis l'autre problème c'est
l'absence de stratégie c'est à dire que
là on a des gilets jaunes qui appellent
à reprendre les ronds-points méprendre
les ronds points c'est pas ça qui fait
qu'on prend le pouvoir non c'est certain
ils essayent de se rappeler au bon
souvenir des politiques et les quelles
politiques n'ont jamais eu de réponses
structurelles pour l'inoculation comme
ceux qui la connaissaient pas ils ont
entendu qu'elle existait mais la voix de
loin mais alors qu'on a des plans
banlieues tout le temps cette population
saisie de nous on n'a pas de réponses
structurelles ont besoin d'une prime de
100 une indemnité je sais plus comment
elle s'appelle avec classe moyenne ne
tient pas cela qui est quelque chose que
les gens prennent comme un mépris encore
une fois c'est à dire que c'est une
population on la connaît cette
population périphériques qui fait que
vous vous dites les sales boulots et
premier de corvée comme ils s'appellent
et qui voit que la croissance revient
mais qu'ils n'en voient pas les fruits
en tout cas ils voient pas la
répartition chez eux et je pense que
c'est extrêmement dangereux pour le
gouvernement
de rester sur cette position là et de
dire regardez ça repart 6% de croissance
le pays est merveilleux tout va bien se
passer sauf que ces gens là ne le voit
pas